what's going on guys
last night was the 87th Academy Awards
where Hollywood broke their arms patting
themselves on the back so damn hard so
now it's time for the third annual
grouchy Awards where we celebrate the
best and worst from the Oscar telecast
we asked Twitter should we be mean
should we be nice you guys said yes
minas JK Simmons from whiplash but first
let's put this black case in a
plexiglass box for a bit that will never
pay off first foul of the night is the
stop touching my face award the nominees
are Kerry Washington
for getting up in this guy's face Jared
Leto for trying to adjust Patricia
Arquette's makeup and the winner is John
Travolta haven't you done enough please
release Miss dazeem are you trying to
take her face off mister Travolta I
don't know why they keep bringing you
back for the Oscars but I sincerely hope
they keep doing it every year from now
on this is an exciting first time award
the Dumb and Dumber award goes to Jared
Leto and David O yellow o take a look at
this
I applaud us we notice the blue in the
red suit good job us you know what the
show left a little to be desired but the
speeches were excellent the nominees for
best speech of the night Patricia
Arquette Best Supporting Actress for
boyhood common and John Legend grand
more the screenwriter for imitation game
Eddie Redmayne best actor and the winner
is JK Simmons for telling everyone to
call their parents call your mom call
your dad
don't text don't email call them on the
phone tell them you love them okay so
it's 1053 on the west coast
that means it's 153 on the East Coast
where my mama's I'm gonna call her right
now hello mom oh yeah uh JK Simmons told
me to call you how are you
I just wanted to say hello I love you
and thank you for picking up love your
mom okay oh wow
alright bye hope shuns money loosen your
tie and take off your belt it's the to
casual award the nominees are Chloe
grace Moretz for having her hands in her
weird dress pockets this dude in a scarf
trying to finish his pseudo coo while
accepting an award this excited audience
member cheering America's incarceration
rate we live in the most incarcerated
country in the world
and the winner is Michael Keaton for
chewing gum like nobody's business
you know what it was inappropriate just
do your thing you didn't win so I just
hope you didn't leave the gum under a
seat at the Dolby theater next up is the
train wreck the nominees are Terrence
Howard for not knowing how to read our
next film our next film is amazing
bumping up against the microphone as
potent and uncompromising as Turing
himself and pretty much jacking up his
whole presentation the next nominee Sean
Penn for telling a racist inside joke to
the entire world who gave this son of a
bitch's green card Birdman and the
winner for biggest trainwreck award Neil
Patrick Harris you told jokes that went
over like this this next presenter is so
lovely
you could eat her up with her spoon
you're humorous banter stuff like this
first time here
yes and Neil I know you're a magician
but when that thing start to unfold more
and more and more I was like no we're
already half hour over get to Best
Picture oh my god I wish Ellen was
ordering pizza oh my god where's the
selfie
last year we fixed the Oscars now we're
gonna fix the host let's welcome our
resident fixer Nick Mundy Nick hey
what's up hey this is easy
hi Oh Tina Fey hire Amy Poehler get key
and Peele it's easy but now you know my
favorite part of the Oscars was there
was a shot where you saw Oprah and then
Stedman and then then the rocks in their
saddles tostão bringing up the world uh
you know my other favorite part uh of
the Oscars was when the rock presented
it was good it's just classy looking in
the tux
clean tux actually you know what you
know what you know who should host the
Oscars Dwayne the rock Johnson the guy
can sing the guy can dance they're great
when does he ever sung and danced and
wrestling hey Dwayne the rock Johnson
your next host of the Oscars this would
be the best were you flinging up its
time like heal our Castro Street halls
man that is ours that is our doll
someone stop him Nick Mundy everybody
you might think I'm exaggerating but I'm
not the greatest moment in Oscar history
award goes to Jack Black who said scream
junkies several times
he's actually saying screens are genes
yeah no he's not seeing screen junkies
love you jack black drop thunder school
rock oh goody everybody's excited for
the best seat filler award the nominees
are this girl this other girl and the
winner is John Stamos
what the hell were you doing at the
Oscars man Stamos that boy goes yogurt
really must be treating you well this
award is very prestigious it's the gift
of the night and the winner is David Oh
yellow Oh telling us how everybody felt
about the night all right we just spent
some time crapping all over the Oscars
but I think we need to bring in a little
positivity for that the lovely ladies of
clever welcome welcome everybody so
please tell us what you think of the
Oscars
everything with awesome amazing hair and
makeup Eddie Redmayne won for Best Actor
look all I cared about and Julie Andrews
up there you know what I disagree with
most of that crap but please who do you
think should have won Best Picture let
us know in the comment section below
best answer is going to get a screen
junkies t-shirt if you want to see more
of the fantastic cover from the very
talented win from clever please click on
the link at the end of this video or
click on the link in the description
below I want to thank you for watching
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter hit
them up on Twitter bye bye are you
looking for razor-sharp pivots pinpoint
stops
don't ever forget my face hell you want
Mike